esta es la denominada jornada nacional
de lucha en la que los maestros del perú
salen a las calles del país para exigir
al presidente pedro castillo que cumpla
sus promesas de campaña y atienda las
demandas de la población reclama mayor
presupuesto para la educación e
incremento de salarios hoy este
trabajador de distintas organizaciones
el ciutat lo cite como sustento el
general padre de familia y le estamos
diciendo al gobierno que el 6 por ciento
del crédito la educación es una
necesidad
un derecho constitucional y por todo lo
que corresponde es simplemente respetar
los criterios
de
renuncia
del concurso público
le hemos planteado concretamente su
renuncia por es que tiene
responsabilidad funcional y
responsabilidad política en la
filtración de la prueba única nacional
que está con un montón de vicios cuya
exigencia los metros contratados es que
se anule se programe una nueva prueba y
lógicamente en la renuncia por
responsable funcional y político los
maestros además se exigen a pedro
castillo garantías sanitarias para el
retorno la presencialidad a las aulas en
el 2022 esta crítica situación se
produce cuando el fondo de las naciones
unidas para la infancia unicef ha
colocado a perú en los últimos lugares
de sudamérica en el retorno a clases
presenciales con un 4.4 por ciento
[Música]